ce matin les stigmates de l'incendié
était encore bien visible
une forte odeur de fumée est à côté de
la mairie de clairegoutte les habitants
sont venus constater les dégâts c'est le
cas de jacques raymond 66 ans il vit ici
depuis tout petit c'est symbolique quand
la main à tout le monde aime bien les
mairies une autre village suite teneur
du linge de klout et on est à l'écologie
en battant les deux classes alors je
pense que deschamps de cabourg t'as un
peu qu'on veut dire ça va leur faire du
mal au coeur comme moi j'ai mal au coeur
hier soir il était comme beaucoup de
vent les flammes c'est à 18h30 que cet
incendie s'est déclaré
d'importants moyens sont alors déployés
37 pompiers 13 engins
l'incendié est assez vite maîtrisé on a
la partie toiture du bâtiment qui est
totalement détruite asik un appartement
puisqu'il y avait une personne qui
habitait dans un appartement dans ce
bâtiment depuis l'extérieur
le maire de cette commune de 400
habitants découvrent l'état d'une salle
particulièrement importante pour lui
c'est la salle de 2 du conseil
c'est la salle où des lignes des
délibérations sont prises et puis c'est
la salle où où les gens se marient c'est
la salle où voulez vous les avez les
grands événements familiaux se déroule
où les gens s'expriment donc c'est c'est
d'autant plus marquant des archives
déplacées à l'intérieur du bâtiment
l'après midi même sont partis en fumée
tout comme la collection de plus d'une
centaine d'oeuvres d'art dont l'artiste
robert altman avait fait don à la
commune quant à l' incendie
il se serait déclenchée dans les combles
au des travaux électriques étaient en
cours pour l'instant la piste
accidentelle est privilégiée